it seems like detroit whether or not
y'all are like hanging out together yeah
that's not what i'm saying it just seems
like there's a movement it's an
understanding for sure and and it seems
like it's at least in a respectful way
as opposed to you know because i feel
like that might kind of been the issue
with detroit in the past i know it was
it was it was the friction it was the
mis understanding the lack of
communication you know what i mean like
i don't think that
some of the brothers before us
felt as if it was enough money for
everybody we get it we know it's enough
money for every [ __ ] body like
and we all got the same
content basically we rap about the same
[ __ ] we rap on the same beats down there
like and if it ain't the same we still
talking about the same [ __ ] just in
different ways
and and everybody's succeeding at it so
that just show you it's enough
money it's enough opportunity it's
enough listeners and followers for every
[ __ ] body everybody in detroit rap
scene got a relationship somehow some
way
everybody know each other some [ __ ]
might talk to might not talk to the next
[ __ ] or something you heard some [ __ ]
entourage may not however it is it's
still an understanding like we not gonna
embarrass this [ __ ] that we ain't gonna
make
anybody look bad for the scene we all
feel like